Добра дружина знає своє місце,
ніколи не скаржиться, коли чоловік надто пізно повертається додому
або взагалі не прийшов ночувати,
завжди зустрічає його з роботи з готовою вечерею,
причепуривши перед тим себе та дітей,
а після вечері подасть йому подушку та зніме йому взуття.
Це не фантазія якогось затятого сексиста,
а цитати з британського порадника для доброї домогосподарки,
передрукованого в Німеччині в 50-ті роки минулого століття.
У житті жінки є лише 2 запитання:
Що мені вдягнути та що приготувати?
Схоже, саме про таких жінок досі мріють українські чоловіки.
За даними нещодавно оприлюдненого соцдослідження,
70% опитаних вважають, що жінка
має бути гарною господинею,
66% - що вона має догоджати чоловікові
і бути поступливою, 63% - що жінка має
піклуватися про маленьких дітей
і 37 - що вона має заробляти менше від чоловіка.
Ми вирішили з'ясувати, як це в Німеччині.
Майже кожен третій татусь у Німеччині користається можливістю
піти у відпустку з догляду за дитиною.
Бодай на кілька місяців.
Також зростає кількість чоловіків, які свідомо
хочуть ділити зі своєю партнеркою хатню роботу та виховання дітей.
Особливо серед молодого покоління.
Майже 60% німецьких чоловіків віком до 30 років
погоджуються з тезою, що татусям слід скоротити
свою зайнятість, допоки діти ще маленькі.
Хатня робота у Німеччині все ще залишається цариною жінок.
Вони витрачають у середньому
164 хвилини на день на прибирання, приготування їжі
та прасування - в той час, як німецькі чоловіки
пітніють за цими справами лише 90 хвилин на день.
Також у парах, де обоє працюють,
більшу частину хатньої роботи виконує жінка.
Тим не менше німецькі чоловіки хатньої роботи не цураються.
Найохочіше вони готові куховарити та ходити на закупи,
найменш охоче - прасувати.
Понад 80% німецьких чоловіків вважають,
що стосункам у родині йде на користь,
коли обидва партнери працюють.
І це не питання грошей. Лише менше половини поділяють думку,
що жінці не обов'язково працювати, якщо чоловік добре заробляє.
Тим не менше чоловіки у Німеччині все ще заробляють
в середньому на 20% більше, ніж жінки за ту ж роботу.
Так само лише незначний відсотків жінок змогли
піднятися на верхівку кар'єрною драбиною у великому бізнесі.
Чого не скажеш про політику - ФРН ось уже
четвертий термін поспіль керує жінка.
У той час як українські чоловіки, схоже, дуже цінують
у дружині поступливість та прагнення догодити чоловікові,
німецькі чоловіки у стосунках найбільше цінують
вірність, довіру,
повагу та здатність посміятися одне з одним.
Нині дедалі більше німців розглядають старий поділ ролей,
коли він - годувальник, а вона піклується про дітей
та домогосподарство, як пережиток.
Сім'ї будуються на рівних правах.
Щоправда, активну гендерну політику нині поділяє лише третина чоловіків.
Решта німців переконані, що
для рівноправ'я жінок та чоловіків у Німеччині
зроблено вже достатньо.